we are kicking off season seven of
American Ninja Warrior and we promise to
bring you some of the biggest stars on
the planet and these guys the try guys
from BuzzFeed hi Matt Iseman alongside
former NFL defensive end Akbar
gbajabiamila look if you got the name
try guys you got to believe they're
gonna come up there and do their
absolute best a lot of times we talk
about it's not necessarily the athletic
ability it's the courage and it's the
determination
Ninja Warrior is one of the peak fitness
competitions in the world I think it's
all about brains
I think physical fitness is overrated
everything they do looks impossible and
they fail at it my therapist said
positive thinking is really important I
have no chance
no matter what you guys should just be
proud of yourself and excites are you
saying that talent and preparedness has
nothing to do with this that's what I'm
here I don't you made that up
I think most the audience isn't really
quite familiar with the actual training
involved that they have to make sure
it's down pat before they get onto that
course I started out with gymnastics
when I was a lot younger and then
transition into snowboarding and diving
and trampoline and then freerunning
parkour let's see I I do that thing what
do you think so do the best just look at
it you guys I'm gonna have to say
definitely Jordan I have a well-rounded
skill set being a former gymnast current
CrossFitters who's the cutest it's gotta
be Eugene Maui's Eugene might have some
trouble obviously but otherwise I think
there's no one else's chances are real
good
[ __ ] it I'm doing it a lot of people
overlook them and they think it's the
first one it's easy and it's the
opposite Ninja Warrior cat style I don't
like the cat technique do you me out
when you do it you have to yeah cat was
the most adorable sounding method and it
was the best one yeah
it's the big man sporting four eyes key
you look at a guy this big you better
expect he's gonna dominate this cool now
that I think I can do it it's gonna be
easy no problem
once we fly past the core double step
grabbing a rope swinging landing on a
platform this trampoline is delightful
Oh God nailed it if you want to jump
through the rope so you want to jump to
it because then you when you grab her
everything's me pulling you down no no
Zach has got a different type of
strength he's got testicular strength ha
ha the Rope may or may not have gotten
caught on my nuts it's all good now and
he's so serious he's doing it without
his glasses looks like he just a walk in
the park I would say a run in the park
cuz once you get on it it will
completely drop hate following all of an
interval warrior courses potential time
yeah I'm aware guys fantastic hair it's
Eugene I love Eugene scared like you say
it but more than that I love this guy
speed he's definitely gonna be the guy
to look for well it is American Ninja
Warrior Eugene does have an advantage in
that regard before that so they're
tilted in different directions but they
spit so you need to get your realism
swing grab the next one keep swinging so
once we pass the buckets with these
what's next it looks like you're gonna
have to go from one unstable bridge
down to a [ __ ] and try to catch the
other one first of all who here can do a
pull-up hey I know you think I'm not
pulling because I'm not moving can't do
it I'll also pose in front of it now
we're getting serious the try guys not
great athletes so actually they
recruited someone with some skill
it's the try girl Jordan we can do what
the guys can do and sometimes even
better than that about the work Wow what
advice do you have for that just go fast
and keep your chest up a lot of people
lean forward to it so they run right
into the wall you want a hug yeah I do I
do want a hug you talk about a guy with
the lower body strength man is that guy
and he gets it from soccer and it gets
it from the support of Ned's wife wow
that was a really fun day I'm completely
ready for Ninja Warrior oh you sure
about that why does it smell like butts
in here it smells like straight-up butts
what's the likelihood I get to hit the
button make like as a team we are one
complete Ninja Warrior the try guys
they're going to participate tag-team
style I think is the first and only tech
team these guys will be getting so each
one will attempt an obstacle when they
hit the water they will then swap out
and move on an hour before we run the
course they're still building it I don't
feel safe because there's still there's
a grain I've been practicing extensively
by saying positive affirmations to
myself in the mirror zach is completely
delusional positive thinking isn't gonna
get him anywhere there's so much trading
involved everyone here out there who's
been waiting in line for a week they've
been working at this for years I've not
gonna pull up because I don't need them
my wife and her mother
coming today I better not mess it up for
them today the culmination of it all I'm
probably at my worst I'm gonna fall in
some water for NBC dad in the starting
watching looking at this body type the
one thing I wish you would try is a
little more clothing I part I don't like
his shorts by the way another great
athlete with an injured hand let's take
a look at what he's doing there not a
strong start there on the quintuple
steps no it's not a strong stuff and
it's not it's just me I think he did
he's looking a little bit like an
injured cat here oh you roaming meow on
the quintuple steps
well got attacked like a tiger get your
pet spayed and neutered and maybe get
Ned spade and neuter to having a little
trouble here hung up he really seemed to
enjoy that last landing on the quintus
is an odd celebration in the middle of
the course and that's life yeah I never
thought we'd see you know check out the
explosion here on the replay his best
angle is from behind eyeball well let me
tell you you talk about the best gluteus
maximus and minimus and medius it's
coming from there but now it is time for
the big man all six three or six nine as
we made estimates get it right accepted
well with those glasses he looks better
suited to attacking a math problem but
so far a strong performance out of kids
are just call him a nerd but now the
circle slider and perhaps the weakest of
them Zach a man who said positive
thought was gonna get him through this
and carry him to the buzzer oh boy here
go Zach bring out the brick phone keep
your elves keep your transition they're
out of zach not a great athletic
approach that's got to be one of the
worst transitions I've ever seen on
American Ninja Warrior
you can tell he try to reach out there
what was he he was hoping he get wet he
said Zach hadn't showered in a while so
there is that benefit there it is he
smells better look at that offering to
support the try guys brothers to the
bitter
but now Eugene trying to tackle here the
tilting table this is the man we've been
waiting for this is the showstopper here
it is right there
I see you go for it doesn't slow him
down he'll feel that one tomorrow strong
below and now we're getting serious the
try guys look at that stumble and a
determination to get through Akbar that
is athleticism at its best right there
you can go he has internal bleeding he's
still made I'm impressed well now it's
your Danube out to get into the basket
Ahsan Haque why this could be a tall
approach here for and not Zach for this
look at the transition great body
control out of Jordan but now and a bit
of noble plan that you've got to use all
for here Jordan if there's ever cool
right now core move you gotta make it
make that leap make that and Jordan goes
down getting wet Akbar a great choice of
words as Jordan ends up in the water and
now Keith on the hourglass drop I expect
big things at a key I mean he's a big
guy six feet three inches of Keith I
think he's got a great shakes off he's
six six seven I think it's gonna grow
with every telling get to one of the
quickest failures we've ever seen let's
take a look now the Warped wall the
final obstacle 14 feet of we are back to
Ned tri guys having surprising success
can they get up I believe obstacle
all right he's just testing out the
Warped wall this is a better remove
they're 14 feet against Eugene I can
feel it I am literally sweating right
now this is the power of visualization
I've seen it now do it I only got the
locomotive I think I can
one last attempt for net if you're the
try guys
this is the time when you have to try I
haven't seen ed look this bad since I
saw him in the lingerie get to the top
it's a blast at all coming on a slide
and it is over for Hall well even Zack
was disappointed Ned and that's saying
something
now it all comes down to this Eugene one
last attempt for the try guys 14 can you
see this is you are sweating profusely
and I think what we just saw is one of
the greatest performances in the history
of American
but I love look at that they're going
they look like teenage girls who just
science sink what was that celebration I
don't know
I'm ashamed for them but they did it the
try guys are American Ninja Warrior
the really team where it was okay to
advance even if you failed did that boys
learn if you could always advance after
failing life would be great yeah that's
a great and awesome attitude right back
my therapist was wrong positive thinking
is [ __ ] I'd rather watch it on TV
while eating six frozen pizzas seeing
this pinnacle of achievement is so
inspiring I can see how people dedicate
their lives to this I am extra motivated
and I'm coming back next year what will
we try next yes well that's captain
unbelievable start to the season of
American Ninja Warrior is the try guys
proven there do guys Aybar try hard or
go home one of the most amazing things
about having these try guys out here is
watching them with so little training
athletically how much they truly tackled
in their background from USC fighting to
stripping right there